all week we're looking at healthy habits
instead of resolutions for the new year
that might speak to you the term
self-care can mean different things to
different people but the payoff for
everyone is tending to your own needs to
make sure that you're as mentally
physically and for many spiritually
healthy as possible
so how do you take care of yourself when
there are so many others tugging at your
time
so self-care has two parts the first
part of self-care is mindset and the
second part is a behavior speaker author
and leadership coach debra grayson regal
says caring for yourself is a must and
attainable the belief that taking care
of myself is important taking care of
myself is healthy taking care of myself
helps other people
that is already something you can do
that doesn't take a lot of time regal
encourages that simple pleasures are
often the easiest escapes i have hand
lotion that reminds me of a trip to
paris that i took because i bought it
there and so i can just rub that on and
bring myself back to a little bit of a
vacation carving out time for you can be
calling a friend you enjoy laughing with
going for a walk or run with a change of
scenery scheduling an extra play date
for the kids while you get a pedicure
take a bobble bath or even savor every
sip of a cup of coffee small doses of
joy that can help reduce the stress
self-care done
one to three minutes at a time really
adds up over a day over a week a month
and a year sometimes the best way to
take care of yourself is to set
boundaries and learn to say no nicely
and to be able to say to somebody no
i apologize i can't do that no next time
there's strength in that but we need to
take care of ourselves before we take
care of others no is a whole is a full
sentence executive life coach adam
jablin says not only is there power in
saying no to others to make time for you
but your you appointment goes in your
day planner schedule me time schedule me
days
if that's possible
but always have it on your calendar
javelin says just like a business
meeting or your kid's soccer game and
homework it's a commitment worth keeping
and investing in self-care will pay off
for you and everyone else who gets your
time anything that overloads our brain
is going to interfere with our ability
to communicate collaborate make
decisions engage in rational thinking
all of which will make it harder for us
to have healthy relationships with other
people and having
really healthy relationships is one of
the hallmarks of having a happy and
healthy life
all that makes me want to take a bubble
bath regal and javelin agree the
increased isolation has caught that
caused by the
pandemic excuse me has created an
enormous amount of people with
depression and so it's more important
than ever right now to care for yourself
and reach out if you need help with the
burdens and the stressors in your life
and that can be a phone call to a friend
it can be a support group it can even be
just getting together with
friends or maybe even a therapy session
or two or however many you need but
really taking care of your mental health
takes care of your physical getting out
and doing physical activity takes care
of your mental and all of that and
javelin was saying adam was saying you
know i put everything in my calendar
everything time for me
time for god time for work i mean he
said i don't skimp on scheduling because
if you don't make time for it in your
planner you won't do it i would i feel
like that would add stress to me like oh
my gosh there are all these things i
have to do today darn it but it's right
if you had to plan out like here's a
block of time i'm not going to do
anything i'm going to sip a cup of
coffee and be good with it no jasmine on
our floor crew just fine
mode
zen mode
all good advice